SIERRA: Hey, everyone! Just a heads
up that this is our last episode of
the season. ﻿We're going to be taking
a break to dive into new episodes and
we'll be back in the late-Spring. In the
meantime, keep an eye on your feed for
extras and the Season 4 trailer. Until the,
thanks for listening - on with the show!
SIERRA: It can be tough to try and make lifestyle
choices that will help build a healthier world.
Over and over, we find out that one of our
habits is contributing to climate change,
inequality, or the destruction of earth's
biodiversity. Even habits we thought were healthy.
Take seafood. For years we were told that
fish were an important part of a good diet.
But now we are learning that many of the fish
we are used to eating are threatened species.
Seafood is the largest traded food commodity
in the world, and it plays an essential role
in our global diet. For some people, fish are
a luxury, but in many of the world's poorest
and fastest-growing populations, it's a matter of
survival. At the same time, relentless industrial
fishing methods are pushing many species to the
brink. If things don't change, our fishing habits
could devastate ocean biodiversity and deplete a
resource that humanity needs in order to survive.
Fish are in trouble. But the
solution may not be what you expect.
I'm Gabrielle Sierra and this
is Why It Matters. Today,
will there always be plenty of fish in the sea?
BBC: We have massive and widespread overfishing
Teen Kids News: 76 percent of the world fish now
are fished at capacity or
overfished and collapsing.
The France 24 Observers: In the last 50 years,
the earth has lost half of its marine life.
BBC: We have completely destroyed the
natural balance of fish in the world's ocean.
SIERRA: So, are we going to run out of fish?
KURUC: If the current way that humans are
fishing continues and the current practices
remaining unchecked, that doesn't set
up a good scenario for our future.
Hi, my name is Michele Kuruc and I'm the vice
president for Ocean Policy at the World Wildlife
Fund in the United States. The pressure, the
amount of fish, the frequency, the quantities
that fishermen are taking out are really causing
many stocks to be in very bad shape in terms of
their future viability. I mean, fish is one of the
most heavily traded food commodities that we have.
SIERRA: Fishing really is a big business. In 2018,
the global export market reached an estimated
value of $164 billion dollars. Asia is the leading
region in the fishing industry, with China, South
Korea, Japan, Taiwan, and one outlier - Spain-
fielding the most vessels globally. The European
Union, the United States, and Japan are the three
places that consume the most fish by volume.
KURUC: And it's really valuable, many
different species are very high cost,
so there's a lot of profit to be made in
catching fish. We have these man-made causes,
these drivers, these threats that are caused
by just better technology, bigger boats,
better refrigeration, easier methods of transport.
And then we have some of the man-induced natural
factors like climate change, which are also
changing the water quality, the composition,
the acidification of the water that fish call
home. And some species can't adapt that well.
They move to different parts of the ocean
to have a more hospitable climate. And that
then raises lots of political issues
about who gets to catch and how many.
SIERRA: If you have ever gone fishing, you know
the drill—a rod, a line, a hook, some bait,
and maybe a boat. But modern-day industrial
fishing looks nothing like that. The boats in many
fishing fleets are essentially gigantic floating
factories. Inside they have all the machinery
necessary to process, freeze, and package hundreds
of tons of fish per day. Guided to schools of fish
by sonar and spotter planes, some of these
ships drag nets that are over a mile long,
snaring whole schools of fish that they are
after, and many that they aren't after, too.
Some of the methods are shocking. Take bottom
trawling, which involves dragging massive nets
across the ocean floor in the hopes of sweeping
up fish. The process destroys coral and other
ocean-floor ecosystems that are essential
for all kinds of life, just for one catch.
As fish populations decline, these
fleets are having to travel further
from land and drag their nets deeper
in order to reach their targets.
BARANGE: When it comes to fisheries, there are
two things that are very important to know. First,
about one in three fish stocks is overfished.
And that means that we are catching more than
the population is able to produce. My name is
Manuel Barange. I'm the director of Fisheries
at the Food and Agriculture Organization of
the United Nations. And I'm also a professor
at the University of Exeter in the UK. So
to have an analogy with banking, you know,
we are eating into the capital rather than just
using the interest. And that doesn't mean that we
are collapsing the population. It's just that
this is not sustainable. We need, actually,
to change that. But we see a dichotomy of what
is happening between developed countries and
developing countries. In developed countries, we
see increasingly an improvement in sustainability
status. In developing countries, we see the
opposite. We see a decrease in sustainability,
increasing volume of problems.
And those are not easy to resolve.
SIERRA: It doesn't sound good. One in three
fish stocks, a.k.a. the types of fish we eat,
are being destroyed faster than they can
reproduce. And many others are on the
edge. The incredible waste and destruction
of industrial fishing fleets are awful to
contemplate. If these are the only options,
then maybe it's time to lay off the seafood.
SIERRA: I mean, are we all going
to just have to stop eating fish?
BARANGE: No, we certainly should not stop eating
fish. And in fact, we should eat more fish.
But that does not mean that everything is
right and good in the world of fishing and
fisheries. You know, when I was born, there
were 3 billion people in the world. If I live
a full life, by the time I die, there will
be 10 billion people. So in my generation,
we've multiplied by more than a factor of three of
the number of people, and we all want to eat; we
all need to eat, and we all have a right to eat.
And so, of course, there's a pressure on all the
food systems, and all food systems in the world,
be that land-based or ocean-based, have impacts.
All of them have impacts. Some of them are
manageable, and some of them are less manageable.
KURUC: Well, you know, right now, about one-half
of the world's population is dependent upon fish
for about 20 percent of their protein, so we're
talking about over 3 billion people. So it's a
very important source, not only of food but of
nutrition, of livelihoods, of economic stability
for communities that could have a whole cascade of
negative consequences if we stop eating fish or if
we continue to have these dangerous practices. So
if, for instance, as you said, we stopped eating
fish, something has to take the place in humans'
diet, and there are many negative environmental
consequences that would flow from that as well. So
it's not a simple yes/no, take one thing out, and
then everything else can operate as it does now.
It's an interconnected system. The ocean obviously
provides not only fish but many other things that
we as humans need for the health of our planet.
SIERRA: The solution can't just be to stop
eating fish altogether. And that's because food
is a bit of a zero-sum game. If the world's
population doesn't get calories from fish,
they will have to get them from somewhere
else. Even vegetarian options, like soy,
can involve deforestation and other
environmental impacts. And in many
parts of the world, catching and eating
fish is a matter of day-to-day survival.
BARANGE: When you look at the global level,
you know, fish production and fish consumption,
you see that we now consume twice the volume of
fish per capita that we used to in the 1960s.
But that is particularly the case in developing
countries. It is particularly the case in Africa,
in the Pacific Islands, in general,
in small island development states,
where there's very few other opportunities for
high-quality protein and very few opportunities
for high-quality sources of micronutrients. Iron,
zinc, vitamins, all those are concentrated in
fish. And those are particularly important
in pregnant women, children under five,
so that is important to recognize, and
fish has a very significant role to play.
SIERRA: Even in the developed world, where it can
be a luxury rather than a necessity, fish can be
an important part of a healthy diet. But to have
sustainable access to fish, we may need to ease
pressure on the handful of species we are used
to eating and think about expanding our palettes.
BARANGE: I think that we humans like
to eat what we are used to eating. So,
we know we go to the shops, and we have a shopping
list that tells us what is that we need. You know,
some people only want to eat cod or tuna. And we
don't have the flexibility of mind to understand
that this is perhaps not the best thing to do. The
best thing to do is to eat the fish of the day,
whatever has been able to be caught that day
or that week by the fishermen in your area.
And part of the problem is that we don't
know how to cook different types of fish,
so there is an element of consuming education that
is quite important to make people see the greater
advantage and the fantastic possibilities that we
have when it comes to fish. I mean, compare it to
land-based animals. What do we have? Cows, pigs,
chickens, you know - you count with the fingers of
two hands. In the case of fish, you have about
600 species to choose. It's a great diversity.
SIERRA: The problem isn’t really fishing
itself. It’s fishing a handful of species
unsustainably. In the global
race to figure out how to feed
billions of people without dooming the
environment, fish are actually one of the
best tools we have. But we’re interacting
with them in a very short-sighted way.
BARANGE: You know, when we talk about the oceans,
it's a single word, right? But it is a very,
very large space. We are talking about
70 percent of the surface of the planet,
and over 90 percent of the habitable space in
the planet; and habitable not by us, I mean,
habitable by organisms. So in terms of this
space that aquatic systems have, it is huge,
and yet we only produce about 2 percent of our
caloric intake in those systems. So we are really
not using aquatic systems to the full. And if we
are to feed 10 billion people, we need to do that.
We can't just rely on land systems, which are
extremely stressed, as we all know. If we have to
increase, for example, agricultural production,
we need to start cutting forests. Who wants to
do that? Or we want to intensify production by
using, for example, genetically modified strains,
and who wants to do that? So they are limits to
the capacity to produce food on land, and we have
not reached those limits in the water at all. And
furthermore, perhaps something that people don't
know. But fish are a very efficient converter of
feed into flesh. There's a particular ratio that
we use very regularly in foul, and that is, how
much feed do you need to produce 1 kilogram of
flesh of 1 organism. And in the case of fish,
that ratio is 1 to 1.3. In other words, we need
1.3 kilograms of feed to produce 1 kilogram of
flesh in the fish. In chicken, it is 1.9. In pigs,
it is 4; in beef, it is 8, you need 8 kilograms
of feed for 1 kilogram of flesh. And this is for
two reasons. First, because fish live in water,
and because of that, they have to invest less
energy into creating bones. Because in water, the
effect of gravity is more controlled, they don't
have to fight gravity in the same way that you or
I have to when we stand up. And furthermore, they
don't regulate their temperature. They actually
just keep the temperature of the water. So when
it comes to looking at what are the advantages, or
what are the sources of food for the future, fish
has so many boxes that you would tick. You have
to invest in fish for so many different reasons.
SIERRA: Compared to land, the ocean has a lot left
to offer. But the fish species we are targeting
are being fished to the brink. Bluefin tuna, red
snapper, halibut, swordfish, pollock, and even cod
are just some of the species under threat. What to
do? One solution is something called fish farming,
also known as aquaculture. Take a section of
ocean, close it off, grow fish, and let the
rest remain untouched. But fish farming is not
as ideal in practice as it can seem at first.
KURUC: So farmed seafood, which is usually called
aquaculture, makes up a really important part
of our fish supply. It's been increasing in
recent years, and now it's almost half. So,
on the one hand, it certainly relieves some of
the pressure on the wild fish stocks that we're
trying to take out of the ocean. But we also
have to factor in what are some of the harms
that aquaculture, farmed seafood, can cause?
And we have this conversion factor because
farmed fish is going to take other things
out of the environment, like mangroves,
areas that are important nursery grounds for fish.
They serve lots of important functions for our
planet. There's an interconnectivity between both
farmed fish and wild-caught fish in the sense that
if you have a fish farm, you need to feed those
fish. And currently, a lot of the fish food,
the fish meal is ground up wild-caught fish that
is fed to these fish that are on these farms.
So the fishing aspect, the wild-caught fishing
aspect, remains really important for both sectors,
both in the wild-caught as well as in the
farm sector. It's not like there's going to
be an easy answer if we switch all of our fish
procurement to fish farming. The other thing
that I think is probably at least somewhat
interesting to know is that not all species
have been successfully farmed. So the variety
of fish that we currently enjoy would go down
dramatically because there are only certain types
of species that can be successfully farmed today.
SIERRA: Aquaculture has its problems, but
the most significant pressure on threatened
species remains traditional wild catches. And
to understand the kind of damage being done,
it helps to take a look at a species
that is not itself threatened...shrimp.
KURUC: So, when shrimp are caught, typically,
there is about one pound of shrimp that's retained
for nine pounds of other fish that are caught
in the same net, at the same time, that are
discarded because they're not part of the target
fishery. In other words, they're not shrimp. They
call them discards, and those are fish that are
typically dead, and they're thrown over the side.
In the world of fishing, this is
sometimes referred to as “bycatch”.
KURUC: They're not utilized, at least, in
many countries. In some countries where
they don't have the luxury of being able to
discard anything, all of it comes onshore,
but in most countries, that's not the case.
And it's not just other fish. Oftentimes,
sea turtles get caught up in those nets
as well. Sea turtles need to breathe air,
they need to surface, they need to come up
pretty often, and those fishing nets that
are fishing for shrimp typically stay down for
a long time. And it's one of the biggest hazards
for our sea turtle population, and that's
the intersection with the shrimp fishery and
trying to figure out ways to save turtles and
still preserve the fishing industry for shrimp.
SIERRA: If that’s not enough, there’s
another major problem with shrimp fishing:
it has been tied to severe human rights abuses,
including modern slavery aboard fishing vessels
in Thailand. In fact, there are a host of
human rights concerns when it comes to the
global fishing industry, and the topic could be a
subject of its own episode. We encourage listeners
to check out the resources in our show notes
to understand more about what’s going on there.
SIERRA: And these unsustainable practices,
this is common across various types of fish?
KURUC: In many, many types of fisheries, they're
looking for the ideal sized fish. Oftentimes,
it means fish that fits on a dinner plate
or they're looking for certain condition
of the fish. They're looking for the fish that is
going to bring them the best price and everything
else. Regardless of whether they've caught
it or not, they'll throw it overboard. So,
there is a very high amount of waste and
the unsustainability comes in. Obviously,
there are finite amounts of population. And so,
you can't only keep 10 percent and throw away
90 percent and not expect that's going to have
an impact on the health of the fish populations.
SIERRA: It's wild to me because that's
not even the illegal fishing part.
KURUC: No. I know.
SIERRA: That's the legal part.
KURUC: I know. I know.
SIERRA: The story of shrimp, and
the incredible waste of bycatch,
is just a window into the practices that
make humanity’s engagement with fish as a
food source so inefficient, and so
unsustainable. And as fish contend
with ever-more relentless methods, other
threats are looming over their survival.
BARANGE: There are many other activities in the
oceans that perhaps go a little bit under the
radar or not as in the radar as fisheries.
For example, coastal zone development,
the removal of mangroves and seagrasses for a
number of purposes, from mineral extraction to the
building of marinas, to the expansion of bays, to
the dragging of harbors, a lot of those activities
that perhaps one does not think so much in terms
of the impact. That is the first thing. Second,
of course, oil exploration and such activities
that do have significant impacts, most of those
activities take place within a narrow band from
the continental shelf, you know, they will be
largely within the first fifty kilometers or so
from the coast. That is the area of the oceans
that is particularly impacted. And I'm including
here pollution issues, runoff from agriculture,
production, lots of nutrients that end up in
the sea, plastic pollution, and the like. Those
areas are very, very highly impacted. When it
comes to high seas further away from the coast,
then the major impact really is climate change,
because the ocean plays a very significant role
in regulating the climate. For example, 90 percent
of the additional heat that we have produced as a
result of global warming sits in the ocean. And a
quarter of the carbon emissions that we emit are
in the ocean. So the ocean has a very significant
role in climate regulation and also a significant
impact. In fact, it is the geographical area that
will suffer the impacts of climate change most. So
when you think about temperature change, what
you will see is that organisms adapt to that.
So all fish tend to have an environmental
window that they feel comfortable in. And
that environmental window might be, say,
from seventeen to eighteen degrees. If
those seventeen to eighteen degrees move
physically because the water is warming,
they will move with that water. And so we expect
a number of species to move towards the poles in
both directions. So that's the first impact,
changes in distribution. There will be also
changes in production. Some species will see a
decrease in production and others an increase in
production. All that has huge implications for
food production in the ocean, at all levels,
if you can imagine, for example, a fisherman
suddenly going out to sea and not finding the
fish that they are used to fishing. And it's not
that easy to change to another species to fish
because some of them require different boats,
different gear, and different technology and
different expertise. And that goes all the way
up the food chain, all the way up to humans.
SIERRA: Fish don’t obey borders. The human
sphere is a lot thornier, and figuring out what
is and isn’t legal at sea can be confusing.
In order to understand how it works, we
turned to friend of the pod and CFR’s own Stewart
Patrick, who is an expert on global governance.
SIERRA: Who is in charge of the ocean?
PATRICK: Well, it's a really complicated
question. The oceans are massive, right?
They cover 71 percent of the earth's surface and
about a third of that falls under the sovereign
jurisdiction of particular nation-states. But
the rest of the oceans, the so-called high seas,
are really the quintessential global commons.
They belong to everybody and to nobody,
and they're governed by an incomplete patchwork of
treaties and bodies. Now, the closest thing that
exists to a constitution for the world's oceans
is the UN Convention on the Law of the Seas.
But UNCLOS, to use its acronym, has a lot of
significant gaps, and that's particularly true
when it comes to conservation and management
of natural resources, particularly fisheries.
Now the convention establishes special rights
for coastal states in their territorial waters,
but also in what are called exclusive
economic zones that extend about 200
nautical miles from shore. But beyond that,
there are a lot fewer rules. Now, in theory,
about 95 percent of the world's fisheries,
including the high seas, are governed by nearly
twenty organizations called Regional Fisheries
Management Organizations. But the rules of these
bodies are limited to their own member states,
and they're often poorly enforced. Plus, they
only deal with a limited number of species, and
they're really uneven in their regulatory power
and their conservation mandate. Another issue is
that a lot of fish species are highly migratory,
and they travel back and forth between areas
of national jurisdiction and the high seas,
and nobody asks for their passports, but
you still have to manage these species.
SIERRA: So what does this patchwork of
laws mean for the health of the oceans,
for fish, for biodiversity?
PATRICK: You know, the impact of
poor governance has been devastating,
and it's getting worse. Advances in technology
have really outpaced any kind of regulations and
stewardship of the oceans. They're permitting
this huge dramatic exploitation of the seas,
and we're getting better at finding and
harvesting fish, but we're doing really
poorly in terms of conserving and managing
these resources that are so critical.
SIERRA: Is it possible to imagine a
new global system that could better
regulate how humans interact
with the ocean and with fish?
PATRICK: The best thing that could be hoped for
would be a Paris Agreement for the oceans in which
the countries of the world all came together and
pledged to do more to meet a global target. In
particular, to protect at least 30 percent of
the ocean in their territorial waters and also
on the high seas from human exploitation. This is
the target of the global campaign for nature. And
it's been endorsed by more than fifty countries.
But the hurdles to getting to this 30% target,
particularly in the open ocean, are immense. The
best immediate step in the direction of protecting
the oceans would be to ratify a high seas
biodiversity convention, which is envisioned as
an implementing agreement under the UN Convention
of the Law of the Sea. The high seas biodiversity
convention would be designed to ensure that we can
serve and sustainably manage marine biodiversity
in areas beyond national jurisdiction. And this
treaty would allow the identification of areas
that are especially fragile and also important
ecologically, including for critical fish species.
These areas would require special treatment.
Now negotiations over this draft treaty have
been going on for several years, and the fourth
and final stage of these negotiations is supposed
to occur by the end of 2021. If this treaty were
ratified, it would mandate environmental impact
assessments of major commercial activities,
including deep-seabed mining. It would also
allow countries to set up marine protected
areas and other area-based management tools,
not only in their territorial waters but on the
high seas. It isn't perfect, but it would help.
SIERRA: Coming to a global agreement on
how we can protect our shared oceans is
perhaps the most important factor in
solving the problem. But there are
also a lot of local laws when it comes to
fishing. And they can have an impact too.
SIERRA: What sort of regulations are there on
the fishing process? How strict is fish law?
KURUC: I love that term, fish law.
SIERRA: I love it too. I think I might've
made it up, but you could have it.
KURUC: I know I've been doing this for a long
time, and I've never heard anybody call it fish
law. So I think that's just great. There are
lots of aspects of fishing, licensing vessels,
operating vessels, who can do that, what kind
of a license do they need to have? What sort of
restrictions are in place? Are there requirements
about almost all of that? The answer is yes,
there are, but what there isn't
is an equal system throughout the
world that respects the rule of law that
enforces all of these requirements at an
equally strict level. Obeying the law hasn't
necessarily been very well-respected either.
SIERRA: Enforcing the law is hard enough within
a sovereign country on land. Enforcing it in the
vast expanse of an ocean system, without any
centralized authority, is nearly impossible.
Experts estimate that at least 30 percent
of the fish caught every year are caught
illegally. The perpetrators range from established
companies to transnational organized crime rings.
Within the realm of illegal fishing,
crimes range up and down the supply chain,
including the targeting of protected
species, fishing in protected areas,
fish-laundering, and mislabeling. One study
found that 36 percent of seafood products in
thirty countries had been mislabeled
by the time the consumer bought it.
KURUC: Measuring how much illegal activity
there is, is difficult. People who break the
law try to hide what they do. In many cases in
fisheries, it's not hard. You look at two fish;
you cannot tell from looking at them if
one was caught legally and one was caught
illegally. They look exactly the same.
It's quite a challenge to put in place
requirements and regulations that can
be easily enforced all over the world.
SIERRA: So are there any examples
of regulations that have worked?
KURUC: I'm glad you asked that question. I didn't
want this to be a story only of gloom and doom.
SIERRA: Me neither.
KURUC: So the short answer is yes, and the region
that has really pioneered some of the most
successful programs is the European Union.
And a little more than ten years ago, they
embarked upon the development of basically
a two-tier program. It looks at the countries
that the EU is buying their fish from to see
if they are adhering to appropriate standards for
enforcing their laws. Do they even have laws? Are
they basically a responsible trading partner when
it comes to how they supply fish to the EU? And
they have used this program to sanction countries,
providing yellow cards, and in some cases,
advancing to red cards. And if you get a red
card, just like in soccer, you're in big trouble,
because the red card basically means that the
trade-in fish from your country is no longer
going to be allowed into the lucrative EU market
until you basically clean up your act and the
EU has given you sort of a clean bill of health.
And so the reason that I feel that that has been
so successful is because it harnesses the very
important power of trade and market leverage
to try to get countries to do what they should
have been doing all along, to say, "If we want to
keep selling, if we want to keep our jobs, we want
to keep our trade, we have got to do better." It
has really changed in a relatively short period
of time, the activities of many, many, many
countries that have not historically been doing
very well. So, I would say that that's probably
the most effective success story when it comes
to a new way to improve how we fish and to try to
make sure that some of the really bad things are
not rewarded by getting additional market share.
SIERRA: The EU’s effort is worth looking
at because it doesn’t just address the
bloc’s own fishing practices. It uses their
economic clout to influence the behavior
of other countries and regions.
With fish, as with so much else,
money talks. And there are a lot of
other good ideas on the table too.
SIERRA: What reforms would you most like to see?
If fish as a food source is something that's
going to continue, that needs to continue,
you know, how do we get eating fish right?
KURUC: One of the biggest problems, and it remains
a problem today in many places, is the inability
to have transparent data about all aspects of
fishing operations and fish trade be available,
so accountability and verification can be
achieved. We need to know who's out there fishing?
How much fish are they taking? What kind of fish
are they taking? Is it really what they say it
is? We need lots of data. We need technology to
really be put to work on some of these issues. And
if there was going to be one major change, that
would be it. So it takes the guesswork away that,
when you're a consumer, standing in your
grocery store saying, "Should I buy that
piece of salmon for dinner tonight? Or is that
really a bad choice because I'm not really sure
about it?" If you think that the government is
already making those evaluations for you, sadly
in most countries, you would be wrong because
they're not. We shouldn't have to be wondering.
We shouldn't have to make a choice about our
food that's based on a lack of information.
There's one other thing. I mean, I talked
about this at a really high systems level,
but I will say that there's also another aspect to
this, and that's at the personal level. And what
can consumers, who really want to be responsible,
who care about the health of our planet, what can
they do? There's a relatively simple thing. And
first and foremost, that is, speak up and ask
questions. And I don't mean that necessarily
in a political sense, although advocacy with
lawmakers is always great. But this is just much
more simple. When you're in the supermarket,
or you go to the fish market, or you're in a
restaurant, and you're thinking about ordering
fish, you can ask the person that you're dealing
with, "Do you know if this is sustainably caught?"
BARANGE: You know sustainability is a bummer.
It is a really difficult thing to do. You are
always chasing your tail, right? So working
towards sustainable use is a difficult thing.
You have to look at every level, what is it
that is failing? You know, why is it that you
are not making something so sustainable?
Now in the U.S., for example, NOAA, the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
estimated that for every fish stock in the US,
to manage them properly, you need the order of $3
million a year. And so if you have twenty species,
you are looking, you know, north of $50 million
a year to manage those resources properly. Now,
for the U.S., $50 million is not a lot. But for
some other countries, it's a lot of money. And
so sometimes countries have different priorities,
and are not investing sufficient effort, money,
infrastructure, people, scientists, to make those
resources sustainable. So there are many things
that can be done, and very many that are not
working well. But the most important is to make
decisions on the basis of science, number one,
and to have political support for those decisions.
If you have those two, you can fix almost
anything. If you follow the science,
and you invest your political
will into following the science,
then fisheries and other food systems are very
sustainable and will feed us into the future.
SIERRA: The ocean belongs to all of
us. It touches every region of the
earth. But its biodiversity is on the deep threat.
It’s not foolish to imagine the overstored ocean,
the ocean that once again teams with fish
for millions and millions of years. Nor
it’s foolish to imagine a sustainable ocean that
continues to provide food for ever-growing human
population. It’s not the one or the other.
We have the knowledge we need to do both.
The only question is whether
we will act on what we know.
For resources used in this
episode and more information,
visit CFR.org/Whyitmatters and
take a look at the show notes.
Have a question or some feedback? Just feel
like saying hey? Send us an
email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio. And,
please please, if you are a fan of the show,
show us some love! Give us five stars and leave
a review on Apple Podcasts. It means so much to
us, and it really does help us to get noticed.
Why It Matters is a production of
the Council on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by
Jeremy Sherlick, Asher Ross, and me,
Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound
designer is Markus Zakaria.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor,
and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Our intern for this semester is Zoe Han.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Additional research and extra help were provided
by Elena Tchainikova. Special thanks
go to Richard Haass and Jeff Reinke.
For Why It Matters this is Gabrielle
Sierra signing off. See you soon!